in a pitch meeting what are the stakes
for the writer and for the executive
well for the writer the stakes are kind
of obvious it's this is going to either
launch my career or advance my career or
this is something I love so much I can't
wait to do it I want them to buy it so
that I can do it and as a side if you
love it that much write it yourself but
but that's a sight so what's at stake
for the writer is this is going to help
my career now that's the same thing
that's at stake for the executive
because the executive is dying to find a
great project that's going to make them
look good because in Hollywood everybody
wants to look good it's about looking
good so if you're picking the winning
horse you're looking good the executive
you're pitching in to most likely has to
go pitch it to their boss so you want to
make sure you give the person you're
pitching to a logline
that they can then take to their boss an
easy way to pitch your project because
they become your advocate and they want
to look good in front of the boss
so they're hoping that your pitch is
going to make them look good okay so
let's say this hypothetical meeting they
don't want the script that you're
pitching but they like you there's a
sensibility about you they like your
style yeah so it kind of your foots kind
of in but not totally right what they
say hey you know this isn't really what
we're looking for maybe you can what
would normally be said what would
normally be said is come back with other
ideas so you would come in and pitch
other ideas or they might say to you if
they really like you we have a project
that we think you'd be great for so
they're pitching you their project it
would be one of two if they really liked
you they didn't respond to that material
or they couldn't use that material but
they wanted to be in business with you
they would be in business with you so if
they say come back to us with something
else yes you come back you you know put
your keys down how soon are you working
on this next thing knowing that there's
a person
that may choose something that I do that
has the ability to launch me how fast am
I getting this to this person and how
urgently am i contacting them again
that's a great question you want to stay
on their radar that's really important
you don't want six months to go by but
you want to be prepared for the pitch so
I would say four weeks I would say a
month to six weeks at the outset and I
would just stay in touch and say I'm
excited I'm working on or have your
representation say I'm only wanted to
come back to you with stuff that's fully
formed or that's ready to pitch now if
they say just come back with some ideas
I wouldn't wait more than two or three
weeks I would come back and I would do I
would use all of your time all of your
energy all of your talent to come up
with great ideas that had a beginning
middle and an end and compelling
characters that you could talk about how
much is too too eager though because you
know somebody could be living in
100-degree weather in the valley with no
air-conditioning and they came out here
and they're so excited and they feel
like this is their chance but the mere
fact that they're so so ready is somehow
repels yes you don't want to be
desperate people smell desperation so if
you came back the next day that would be
too soon
okay if you wanted to wait I wouldn't
even wait I wouldn't even do it the next
week I would wait at a minimum of two
weeks because if you come back the next
day then they will think that you didn't
put time into it on the other hand in
this business the way it works is you
wait you wait you wait and then you get
a call we need it now we want you to
come in tomorrow that actually happens
and you have to be prepared for that
because suddenly something shifted on
the other side of the table and they
need you and they need it right away so
be prepared to do that but don't be the
person that says I can come back in
tomorrow
it sounds like three weeks is a safe
zone it is what's that okay yeah it's a
good barometer three weeks yeah okay
get the meeting on the books though okay
is that right away while you're there no
no no that that's within the next couple
of days say I'm gonna be ready to come
back in I'll let you know it'll probably
be within three weeks should I make the
appointment now or later you talk to
their assistant
you